[Music]
Wow that was an incredible welcome you
know that was very nice but you know I
realized that today's audiences just
really don't know how to give a standing
ovation anymore yeah I thought I'd with
that no it was very nice but you know
the proper standing ovation really you
know should not be a military pose it's
not like this it's much more relaxed in
the back and the hand should be held
about this high and you should look to
your companion with a smile like wow and
then the hand should come up in praise
and drop back down kids these days I
apologize I don't know what they're
doing
thank you so much for being here it's
obviously a thrill for us good friend of
yours on the show last week mr. Martin
Short oh yes honey Matthews and yes he's
he's funny yes in his way in his own way
in his own way and and he told me he
said he's funny like your puppy Conan
was funny
that was a compliment yes for love puppy
we're out of time yeah well he's a we
were talking and one of the first things
he mentioned is that he went on vacation
on vacation I think I'm entitled to a
vacation two weeks a year don't you
think yes why are you insulting my dare
you snap at me it's really going badly
it's going terribly you went to st.
Barts wonderful island it's a beautiful
island yes and I had this theory that
you know there's paparazzi down there
that if I tweeted photos of me where
they like to get photos like on the
beach and things like that that that
would cut down on the paparazzi photos
and it actually actually did okay so I
took photos of me part for example this
first photo here I I tweeted Here I am
body surfing in shark-infested waters
are infested waters and if they note the
scared bathers in the back yeah they
look terrified they're huddled together
which is the worst thing to do initiated
ugly palm tree blocks my ocean views
Here I am taking time away from my
vacation to spend time with st. Barts
village
to help those obviously as we said as
we've established a Martin Short a funny
guy yes you've worked with all the
greats and you know myself aside who are
the best
I had already put that aside dangerously
short on time I don't know that we'll
get to the book no but let's start rates
everything but you uh you you've worked
with so many great my best
ad-lib errs who this for the best top of
their hats interesting there's one that
comes to mind I had just finished
hosting the Oscars with Alec Baldwin and
now I went to the Vanity Fair the Vanity
Fair party which is you know just
crammed with celebrities and I'd stayed
there till 2 a.m. and it was it was time
to leave and I had always admired
Russell Brand I thought he was a very I
still think he's a very funny comedian
yes and I always wanted to meet him and
I was now exiting the party just as he
was coming into the party and so I
passed him and I said said oh I'm going
out just as you're coming in and he said
it's a metaphor
very good